there are really strong parallels
between the preparation and dedication
that it takes to compete on an athletic
level and to compete for the future of
what the digital industrial world looks
like my name is Sam ulstein I'll eat
global innovation GT brands I run a team
called the disruption lab which is all
about creating new and unique ways to
tell our story using emerging media
tools the Olympics has relevance for
everybody around the world whether you
are an athlete and you're competing in
it being a part of the host city or you
know your brand marketer who has the
opportunity to activate around the games
and it's also an opportunity for us to
showcase the work that we do to global
audience you know as marketers when we
get close to planning around our
association with this Olympic Games and
what are the new and exciting ways to do
that we think about content that can
overcome language barriers it can
transcend borders and to really make a
campaign global if you have to embrace
the best of new technologies the two
biggest innovations that change for the
games in rio compared to the last games
in sochi were drone technology and live
streaming platforms drone week is a
five-day live multicast of GE technology
behind a Rio 2016 Summer Olympic Games
being able to show this canoe and kayak
app our engineers in Brazil built to
help that team trained better is a much
better way to tell our story
there's always excitement when you
introduce the element of being live and
unfiltered and unedited tensions are
riding high but the thrill of it is so
exciting with live streaming mainstream
accessible it is easier more than ever
for an athlete to activate their own
media brand and so the walls of directs
fan and athlete interaction have come
down and they've also opened up
opportunities for brands and marketers
who haven't historically had those
traditional media channels now have the
ability to reach so many people with the
right story and I think good content
will find an audience that question
about the right kind of distribution
channel and technology changes so fast
and so frequently snapchat is probably
one of the most creative ways to tell a
story so it is a really important
platform when things are happening in
that moment periscope is I think one of
Twitter's best features and Facebook
live is become so powerful you know
these are all amazing tools to
distribute content for the next Olympics
who knows we might be able to put on a
VR headset and go in a drone and be in
the match ourselves so we're going to be
looking at a whole new set of tools and
channels whether their business
objectives their product announcements
or their more general awareness and
branding about where the company is
going we always think about how do we
make our content very culturally
relevant how do we make people care
about it and if you have the ability to
connect with content when it's live
you're in the driver's seat
Oh